we got Andy no reports from the
post-millennial domestic Terror charges
for five arrested at violent antifa
autonomous Zone near Atlanta the Georgia
Bureau of Investigations has found
explosive devices and gasoline at the
rate the reason this story is newsworthy
is that it actually happened for once
yeah you know if if if the law was being
upheld as it's supposed to be we
wouldn't care to talk about another
bunch of extremists getting arrested
they're supposed to get arrested now
we're like wow look at that they
actually arrested some of them here's
what I see happening this is the point I
was making just in the previous segment
a society has a typically a cohesive one
everybody kind of agrees on the lines
you don't cross when someone crosses
that line everyone is aghast and the
cops are like we're going to go in and
deal with this that meant obscenity laws
100 years ago that meant someone could
go on a street corner and yell something
nasty and they'd be like no no no stop
the stop this and everyone agreed not
good we've now gone so far in the other
direction that you actually have people
throwing Molotov cocktails and in these
cities they're like well you know it's
their first offense and look we're going
to lose votes if we actually prosecute
these people so let's let them all out
of the prisons now there's no
enforcement at all the American people I
mean it's conservatives too
I mean conservatives aren't going to go
to cities and demand this stuff
so unless there was an actual
ramification for not holding people to
account
you know or I should say there is no
ramification for not holding people to
account so it's just not happening this
is this is the breakdown of the
political body or of government or
whatever you want to call it though
they're they're people are being held to
account if for instance they uh prohibit
their children from being castrated
people are being held to account if they
walk into the capitol rotunda with a
horn hat on and crack a Coors Light
people are having the book thrown at
them for that sort of thing pro-life
activists at abortion clinic pro-life
activists at abortion clinics and just
even exposing crimes actual Elite not
just immoral activity which is all that
takes place at abortion clinics but but
actual illegal activity and then who's
prosecuted it's the pro-lifers so the
law the law is being enforced and more
than the law is being enforced against
certain people but you know you look at
say the 19th century early 20th century
and you always hear these Horror Stories
of the Ku Klux Klan getting away with
lynchings or Terror rides or anything
like that you say well they just didn't
enforce the law you know that was yeah
right that is is an imperfect expression
of how the law is enforced and you're
seeing you're seeing precisely the same
sort of thing here it's cultural
tolerance right now our culture is
completely tolerating antifa
conservatives and libertarian types
complain about the violence and that's
and then nothing else happens there is
no cost for a law enforcement division
of any kind if they do not enforce the
law there is a cost right if they do
enforce it when they come out and Target
antifa they can expect more firebombs
and more violence if they don't arrest
anybody what can they expect well there
will be some firebombs and violence from
these lunatics they won't arrest but
conservatives ain't going to do anything
yeah but you do see uh the law of nature
take over when the firebombed Duane
reader when they go into Dwayne Reed and
MOB the store the flash mob and Rob you
know a thousand dollars each so they
can't get felonies in San Francisco
where they made it you're allowed to a
thousand bucks and then Dwayne Reed
shuts down I think it's Duane Reade
don't give me if it's not Dwayne I think
it was Dwayne Reed there's also uh I
think target so you see the market is
reacting to unchecked violence it's not
the right maybe it's not even though
it's culture it's the market itself but
that's part of the culture the mayor but
it's like it's like a team of nature the
mayor the chief of police the the the
the the sheriffs they suffer no
consequence no immediate consequence
it's a long-term thing where your city
starts to fall apart business is shut
down the individual suffers no
consequence at all well only that your
your environment begins to degrade
slowly so what they can move
so these cops these cops who live in San
Francisco they're resigning they're
moving and then it gets worse and worse
and worse and that is an issue of uh of
an individualized society when everyone
just says it's about me and my life
that's what happens when people put
responsibility to the community slightly
above themselves you'll get someone
going out being like I gotta stop this
because you know old man Jenkins down
the street needs this Dwayne reefer's
medication I can't let someone do this
to the community
let's let's break this problem down
because I think it's fair to say that
George Soros invested a lot when it came
to appointing District Attorneys and
attorney generals all throughout the
United States you guys agree with 120
million so so Republicans bought
government to impose his will on what he
thought was right and his will is
punishing right-wingers but letting
antifa go well for the most part it's
the unin the the non-enforcement George
Soros wrote an op-ed about how he wanted
DA's who were not going to go after
people and we're going to give them
lighter sentences that's an inversion
I'm not advocating for Harsh
authoritarianism so I I actually think
cash bail is a problem but I don't know
if we have the solution other than to
expand build more courts hire more
judges but George Soros basically said I
want people who are in the DA's office
who won't prosecute crimes well you got
it and now it's getting worse exactly
but that's not using the government to
do it that's stripping the government of
the ability to stop these people no no
no no no because when the government
sees a right-winger when the government
sees a political crime when the
government sees a way to punish someone
for their political ideas they do it
that's that's the government
when it comes to specifically when it
comes to specifically made a point I'm
going to address your point Luke you
made one point let me address it if
there's a left-wing and right-wing
activists and they both Riot they should
both be arrested what's happened now is
half is being enforced and politically
biased only one side is being let go
this is the government
not enforcing half of it and actually
and and upscaling against the right and
by the way not to be too harsh you know
on the libertarian effect on the
conservative movement but a lot of the
reason why the libs have become so good
specifically over the last 60 years at
wielding the government in a way that it
was not very good actually at before you
saw you know you saw the beginnings of
Woodrow Wilson and FDR but you still had
a lot of conservative political power
within the government a lot of the
reason why we're not good at it anymore
is because the Libertarians convinced
the conservatives that wielding
political power per se is wrong and
immoral and by doing that we conceded
the entire political field and now the
libs run all of the institutions the
conservatives and Republicans being weak
has nothing to do with Libertarians they
decided that for themselves and they
capitulated power they're the ones that
went along with a lot of this nonsense
they're the ones that are literally just
the Democrats of 10 years ago let's be
honest here they're implementing the
same policies and and if there ever is a
political party that hasn't been working
for the American people that actually
screw them over and and gave them failed
promises you're right it's the
Republican Party what's your opinion on
redefining marriage the obergeophile
case and the now the law that was passed
yesterday the quote unquote respect for
Marriage Act radically redefines the
fundamental political institution I
think it's a PR stunt uh in order to try
to Galvanize a base pretty much I have a
marriage I haven't even I haven't even
read the bill I haven't even what about
the concept I don't I don't believe the
government should I don't think you need
permission to marry someone to get a
license from the government well you
always have throughout all of human
history so how come how come now people
no no not always people made bonds and
and specific contracts with each other
without without government sometimes as
well that's not true marriage has always
had a tie either too religion or to the
religion which was usually established
and that tied to the state I'll make
I'll make a single thing that's why
sometimes sometimes religion was more
powerful than this and let me know
specifically but they're always tied
together and I'll address specifically
pre-marriage pre-nofault divorce was a
contract that you could not just break
if you entered into a contract with
someone you had a duty and
responsibility and if you wanted to
break it you had to prove to a court
that was just reason to do so right so a
marriage meant something the reason you
had the government involved wasn't
because they gave you permission it was
because you were saying to another
person I give my life to you I expect
your life in return it's a public act
and it's a public act and if that person
then decided I'm not going to give you
equal like you're giving me your life
I'm not giving you back you would have
your honor courts I need this enforced
and they would say marriage counseling
some kind of relationship counseling
then no fault divorce came in and now
we're at the when the period where
marriage is basically a date you're
dating someone someone there's no
enforcement anymore 40s which I think is
interesting the reason why libertarian
is so popular right now is because in
the 40s America became a militant
authoritarian country it used to be a
liberal Republic and then in 1949 when
they signed they created the liberal
economic order they became this a
military government and they did it in
secret they didn't want want people to
know Kennedy tried to out on the kill
whoever someone killed him and uh who is
they
have an evolution of government from
Liberty Liberty yeah and so what's
happening is the um the anarchists are
pushing back but if you push back too
hard the pendulum goes extreme you don't
want extreme that's what status do left
and right left and right back and forth
more government more government more
government listen I grew up in Poland
when there's still communism there right
the Polish people are adverse to
Communists and to fascists to extreme
left and extreme right this is
essentially the larger ideas that are
Quantified in anarchism in my opinion
because they push back a lot of this
nonsense that feeds each other and
builds on top of each other and in
Poland specifically when it came to
things like marriage right if someone
would be divorced if someone would not
take care of their child after birthing
a child they would be looked upon as a
scumbag there would be social pressures
on that individual for being a scumbag
no one's a very Catholic well during
communism and during when the Soviet
Union had control of of Poland it wasn't
it wasn't mainly the the state that was
enforcing a lot of these morals it was
the church that had a larger impact on
that well it was the church was
suppressed and the church was fighting
the the state so right but my point here
is when when I hear from our libertarian
friends that the conservatives are
actually the ones who are the Democrats
from 10 years ago
is it not true no it's not true the
Libertarians are the ones who are
pushing gay marriage of you so left-wing
that Barack Obama didn't even agree with
it in 2011. they're the ones pushing
drugs they're the ones pushing open
borders they're the ones pushing all of
the breakdown of the family though some
are but I'm not some are yes those are
issues
against I think you unwittingly are
pushing those things but you I don't
think I disagree because I addressed
those problems uh specifically uh what
was the three but I guess the reason the
reason I bring it up is if you ask real
conservatives the real tragedy is around
today what's your view on marriage
they're going to give you the view of
marriage that was held from the
beginning of human history until 2015.
if you ask their views on drug laws or
on a punishing criminals or on
immigration enforcement or any of these
things you're going to get the
conservative point of view and it's
going to be the Libertarians and the
liberals who agree on all of those
issues in a very very radical way
I disagree I think the ideology is is
directly opposed to each other liberals
want more government Libertarians want
less government but but but your biggest
argument is the same as what I'm saying
because it's not when the Liberals use
big government in order to impose their
vote but when the when the Libertarians
uh use this Fantastical utopian aversion
to government to break down the social
order and to break everyone down into to
individuals who are much more easily
collectivized which is which is
something you said brilliant I don't
know where you got this idea that the
base unit of a of a of society is the is
a duality it's a communication between
two or more people a family unit one
individual born in the woods with no
humans is not a human I mean technically
they're human they're not not a person
they're not Society yeah they don't have
man they don't understand language they
don't understand concepts of humanity
they don't understand they're a wild
animal if they're born in the woods yeah
right alone yeah and so you need that
second person and I think to think of
society as The Duality we cannot
function without The Duality because
that's what like it keeps you sane it
keeps you humble it's the man and the
woman yeah I thought that was really
funny The Matrix you see the fourth
Matrix one they made I I didn't know
they went up to four I think I've only
seen through three I think it's funny
because a lot of people said it was
gonna be like woke or whatever but the
plot of The Matrix is literally that you
need a matriarch and a patriarch
together to stabilize reality and not in
a Libertarian Society not only will two
people keep each other sane and rational
but in a in a totalitarian Society two
people will keep each other from falling
victim to the state thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time